>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D. C.
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Good morning, everyone.
>> Good morning.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: It's such
a beautiful day and you all are
such a beautiful sight to look at.
Welcome to the Library of congress.
I'm Betsy Peterson, the director of
the American Folk Life Center here.
And I'm not going to talk
too long because the staff
of the center is going to talk
about our collections and work
that we do in greater detail.
But the leadership of NABS
approached us last spring to talk
about what we could do and
how we could work together
for your conference.
And so we're really excited.
We've been meeting with Dilan
Pritchard for several months
and talking with him on the phone.
So I hope we've got a good
program here for you today.
But I think given the title or theme
of the conference in the tradition,
I think you've come
to the right place.
I would certainly hope so.
And I think we have
a lot of materials,
a lot of primary resources that can
inform and connect with the work
that you do, with the
stories that you tell.
And actually I think
Zora Neale Hurston has
about the best definition
of folklore ever.
Which is folklore is the boiled
down juice of human living.
And I think that kind
of about sums it up.
So we do have that
boiled down juice here.
And please come back
and come back often.
Before I turn it over to the staff,
I just wanted to say one word,
just a note of remembrance about
a colleague, friend, mentor,
Gladys Marie Fry, who I
know many of you knew.
She was a great friend to folklore.
And a great mentor to
many folkoreists as well.
She was a professor at the
University of Maryland,
has written two fabulous books,
Night Riders and Black Folk History,
and Stitch from the Soul: Slave
Quilts from the Antebellum South.
And we're very sad to
hear of her passing.
We know you are too, but we know
her spirit is with us here today.
And I think throughout
your gathering.
So with that said, I'm going to
turn this over to Todd Harvey,
the curator, one of the curators,
reference librarians here
at the American Folk Life Center.
And actually two words.
There are cups, water in the back.
Please get some water
if you need some.
I know some of you have found
the restrooms, but if you need
to find the restrooms,
talk to some of our staff.
And we'll get you all set up.
And hi there.
Okay. Todd Harvey.
[ Applause ]
>> Todd Harvey: Good
morning, good morning.
I take the podium in gratitude,
and I think that you know why.
It's because we work
in the same field
and that is preserving tradition
and continuing tradition.
And I do it from my place, which
is to take care of the stuff.
And you do it out there
in the world.
And we're all part
of the same process.
I have a few words that I think will
help us focus on the talks today.
And I get to talk about
the Library of Congress
which is the oldest federal
institution, cultural institution.
The world's preeminent
reservoir of knowledge,
providing unparalleled
integrated resources
to Congress and the American people.
That's the big bold:
the American people.
Founded in 1800, the library seeks
to further human understanding,
wisdom, by providing
access to knowledge
through its magnificent collections.
So we are the largest
library in the world,
which means we have
the largest collection
of storytelling in
the world by default.
And most of those are here at
the American Folk Life Center.
So let me tell you, the American
Folk Life Center was created in 1976
by an act of Congress, through
programs of research, documentation,
archival preservation, reference
service, live performance, exhibits,
publications and training.
The American Folk Life Center
archive, established by the Library
of Congress Music Division in 1928,
is now one of the world's largest
archives of ethnographic materials
from the United States
and around the world.
Most of our materials and
our programs and our services
to you are found on our website,
and it's a great thing to explore.
You can waste hours and
hours of time looking at it.
I curate the Lomax Collections here
at the American Folk Life Center.
And they are some of the
earliest documentation.
The Lomax's ran our
archive in the 1930's.
And so what I thought I would
do, just to start things off,
is to play a couple of
examples of Lomax materials.
This isn't strictly storytelling,
but it's personal narrative.
It's spoken word materials.
And I think it will
give you some insight
into what we have in
our collections.
And so the Lomax's,
here's Mr. Lomax,
John Lomax with an unidentified man.
Maybe someone will know who he is.
Probably somewhere in Georgia.
Here's the younger
Lomax, with Sonny Terry
and Brownie McGhee, these guys.
Recording girls singing
in San Antonio 1934.
Alan Lomax in action in the 1980's,
explaining to the world why
cultural equity is the way we should
all live.
So I want to play you an example.
This is [inaudible] since 1939.
But the dust jacket you can see is
side A number two, The Cat's Story.
[ Inaudible ]
So he places himself in a
traditional tale, right?
It reminds me of some of the jack
tales, the kind of magical cat
who appears and disappears
in the haunted house.
And you know, it's a motif that you
find all over American storytelling.
But in this case it's from
Texas and there he is.
I guess he was a mule driver.
So the next performer
I have for you,
Alan Lomax called her the
greatest voice in American song,
Vera Hall from northwestern Alabama,
from Livingstone area Alabama.
And he recorded her in
1948 for about 15 hours.
He did oral history with her.
And it was the only time I
believe she left Alabama.
He brought her up to New York
to make these recordings.
And the recorded her first
in 1937 and last in 1959.
So at the American Folk Life
Center archive we have a lot
of Vera Hall recordings.
And this is one of her
best, The Wild Ox Moan.
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]
Of course the library has
Bessy Smith recordings.
[ Laughter ]
Not today, but we can certainly
help you when you come back.
I know Bessy Smith was quite famous.
I would listen to Vera Hall
alongside with her I think.
So I have one more.
I love that, because
it's improvised, right?
And she's talking about what's
happening today and it feels
like it could go on as
long as it needed to go on.
And do you have a question?
>> Yes. You know what, I
understand also that --
[ Inaudible ]
[ Laughter ]
>> Todd Harvey: Do I know?
I was listening but I can't
tell you what the words were.
It is online, for what it's worth.
Let's listen to one more.
This is Mohave Plantation,
Moon Lake.
It's in one of those Islands in
the Mississippi in Coahoma County.
And this is a nighttime
service that they recorded
in a little country church.
And this is near the end of it,
so it's hard to imagine this
has been going on for an hour.
And what I love about this is
it has multilayered events going
on at the same time, right?
And so there is preaching, there is
singing and there is some speaking.
So I just have a little bit of it
to play for you and you're going
to have to come back and
listen to the whole thing.
[ Laughter ]
[ Singing ]
[ Shouting and cheering ]
[ Applause ]
All right, so I can imagine
there might be a few questions.
But I want to -- Thea says I
can take a question or two.
But we have to move on
soon because there are lots
of people to talk to today.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: We have
about five minutes to take a couple
of questions and I have a microphone
so that it's easy for
Todd to hear you.
>> Do your recordings
have English subtitles?
>> Todd Harvey: No, they do not.
These are archival recordings.
These are discs and things
like that, the real thing.
>> Is there a way to go online
to get some of this information?
>> Todd Harvey: Yes.
>> What do you do to go online?
>> Todd Harvey: American
Folk Life Center website.
>> That's it?
Okay, thank you.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: Also,
if you look in your packets,
Dana Bell has created -- one of
our amazing staff people here
at the Library of Congress --
has compiled a guide to resources
that are online that
you can access remotely.
She's here at the back of the room
and she'll be here during the break.
You can ask questions.
Dana, can you raise your hand?
Here she is.
She created this resource guide.
>> Todd Harvey: Thank you, Dana.
>> I just wanted to suggest
that I know that some
of the words may be a little
bit difficult to understand,
but I would hope that most of
us can appreciate the sounds
and the feeling and the emotion.
Understanding the period that
the people had come through.
So I don't think we have
to know the exact words.
We should hopefully be
able to surmise what
that whole experience was about.
We're from that root.
>> Todd Harvey: Thank you.
>> I just want to share
a quick statement.
I don't know how many of you
saw me do Voices of Courage.
I did it in let's see, when
we were in Little Rock, right?
So when I went to study,
when I got to IB Wells,
I wanted to include folk life
and I wanted to do games.
And so when I came to the Library
of Congress I looked up Vera Hall.
And I couldn't get the exact
region, but I got the south.
And I used Vera Hall when I played
the Game Song, The Courting Song.
I used Vera Hall's
Courting Song to say
that at this age she would
be courting IB Wells,
but she couldn't court
because her parents died.
And I sing that song
with the audience,
just to let you know
how to use this work.
>> Todd Harvey: So I want
to answer more questions,
but I think it's time
for us to move on.
I'll be here after this.
Okay, go ahead.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Hang on just one second.
>> I don't think I need this.
I look around and I see so many
people here that have these stories
and everything and a lot of
us have made that transition.
Is there a way that we as a group
can start recording our stories
so that they can be found?
You know, so that the
younger generation
that comes after us can hear it?
Because I heard the Vera Hall.
I remember my aunt singing
those songs and things to me.
I said, "Dang, I didn't
even know it."
And I'm a librarian.
I didn't even know.
So what is the best way for someone
to have their stories recorded?
Do you have any type of program
where they have their stories
recorded so it can be added
to the archive, to the Folk Life?
>> Todd Harvey: There are ways.
I will make you a deal.
If you as a group will record your
oral histories, we will put them
in the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Also, just to let you know
that our staff member Guha
Shankar will be talking more
about field work later on
today in your sessions.
But let's thank Todd Harvey.
[ Applause ]
>> Todd Harvey: Well, my stuff
is what you want to hear.
What Megan is going to talk
about is what you have to hear.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Megan Harris: Wow,
that was quite a lead-in.
Thanks, Todd.
Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
Good morning.
I don't know that I've
ever presented
to as enthusiastic
an audience as this.
It's really wonderful
and it puts me at ease
because I am not a
performer whatsoever.
So you'll have to bear
with me a little bit.
Great. Todd's presentation
was actually a great lead-in
to my presentation because I am
from the Veterans History Project.
I am the reference specialist
at the Veterans History Project.
And we're part of the American Folk
Life Center here at the Library.
And it's a project that
you can take part in
and donate stories of veterans.
So it's a great lead-in
to the question
about how can our stories
be part of the library here.
All right.
Let's see.
Okay. So in case you don't know
about the Veterans History Project,
our mission is to collect, preserve
and make accessible the stories
of America's War Veterans.
And we were established
by Congress in 2000.
And since 2000 we're celebrating
our 15th anniversary this year.
Since 2000, we've collected over
99,000 individual narratives.
So quite a lot.
And our emphasis is really on the
social and cultural experience.
Not so much the military
history experience.
We're not so much about
charting how battles were won
and how different regiments
took part in a glorious victory.
It's really more about what
the experience of being
in the military was all about, how
it felt, how basic training felt.
How it felt to leave your family.
Those sorts of experiential
feelings.
And we do this by asking the general
public, so folks such as yourself,
to interview the veteran
in your life
and then donate the oral history
to us here at the library.
We archive it and make it accessible
to researchers who are working
on Ph. D dissertations, who
are working on documentaries,
who might just be wanting to know
more about their own family history.
We make these stories accessible
both in the reading room here
at the library as well as online.
So in terms of our
African American holdings,
stories of African American
veterans, these are some
of the photos that we have
that have been donated to us.
All of these folks here have
taken part in our project.
We have over 3,000
stories of veterans
who have self-identified
as African American.
And you can see that out of the
99,000, 3,000 is only a small part.
And it really has to do with
the fact that we are dependent
on the general public
not only for the stories,
but for the information
about the veterans.
So we can only count a story
if someone has self-identified
as African American.
This is what we call metadata and
it's really important that we know
as much as we can about
the veteran and their story
when they're donated to us.
So it's a small fraction.
There are more veterans than
this that are in our collection.
But that's the number
that we can go with.
About 500 of these are fully
digitized and available online.
And they span every branch,
every conflict from World War II
to the present, including recent
conflicts in Iraq and Afghanistan.
And every rank.
So we have some of the more lauded
stories from Tuskegee airmen
and Montfort Point Marines.
And then veterans who maybe
didn't ever leave the state,
who just served stateside or who
served in more administrative roles.
We are again interested
in all experiences,
and not just combat roles
or storming the beach
or in the trenches,
but all of the roles.
So one of the stories that I wanted
to show you today, I decided to look
at two different collections
just to give you a taste
of what our collections
are all about.
The first veteran is
James Edward Blakely.
He enlisted in the Navy in 1939 and
he served as a cook aboard a couple
of different ships in
the Pacific Theatre.
[ Inaudible ]
Sorry?
Yeah, just like Dorie
Miller, exactly.
Yeah. And just like Dorie
Miller he was stationed
at Pearl Harbor on
December 7th, 1941.
So I thought this was
a good collection
as we approach Pearl Harbor Day.
And John, if you could
play that first audio clip.
So this is part of this collection.
>> About five or six minutes before
8:00, I was on the USS St. Louis.
That's what they call
box-back cruiser.
The word came over the loudspeaker,
"All hands man your battle stations.
All hands man your battle stations.
This is not a drill."
That was where hell on earth began.
We only had probably 50, 60 men
aboard, coming back to their ship.
And when I looked around,
it was a direct hit,
right in the middle of the ship.
In December in Hawaii,
the world is like summer,
and I could see white
uniforms blown sky high.
They never made it.
I don't have to close
my eyes to see that.
>> Megan Harris: So you can see
that Mr. Blakely's story is maybe
different than those that we have
in the Lomax Collection, or those
that Todd talked to you about.
But I think you'll agree
that that account is equally
as important in terms of folk life.
Yeah, so that's Mr.
Blakely's collection.
The next collection that I wanted
to show you is actually
a video collection
from Evelyn Clarisse Martin Johnson.
She was in the Women's Army Corps.
She enlisted in 1941 and she
served in a postal battalion,
which was actually the only all
African American female unit
to serve overseas.
She served in France and
England during World War II.
And John, if you can play that
clip, that would be great.
She talks about her
experiences are overseas.
>> What were your emotions over
there when you did see them?
>> Well, destruction
is heartbreaking.
To see how the schools,
the churches,
the entire communities were bombed.
Because all that destruction had not
yet been cleared up or cleaned up.
And we saw that daily,
where we were.
Because they had bombed Birmingham
before we had arrived there.
And it was the same in rural France.
That was what was sort
of helping you
to wish you were leaving the area
and on your way back to America.
>> Did your military experience
influence your thinking about war
or about the military in general?
>> Well you don't forget it.
There's no way to forget it.
You try not to keep it on your
everyday thinking, but you're going
to think about it especially
when there is
so much similarity of
that going on later.
Like the Vietnam and the Korean
War and all the other wars.
You don't forget that.
>> How did people treat you when
they find out that you're a veteran?
>> Oh, many of them are surprised.
And then when I say World War
II, they say, "Where were you?"
And then I tell them
and they are delighted.
They appreciate the
fact that I did so.
>> Megan Harris: All right, so
those are just two of the stories
that we have in our collection.
They happen to both
be from World War II.
But like I said, we collect stories
from all conflicts,
and even between wars.
So not just limited to particular
conflicts, particular wars.
But anyone who served in US uniform
can take part in our project.
Let's see, all right.
So just really quick, a
couple of other resources.
Like I said, some of our
collections are digitized
and available on our website.
So you can search our website.
We have an online database you
can search by race, by gender,
by service location and unit.
So if you have family
members or if you want
to research the particular
history of a unit,
you can do that with
our online database.
We also have online exhibits.
It's a series called
Experiencing War.
And we released those quarterly
on a number of different topics
and we have right now two different
online exhibits that pertain
to African American veterans.
So you can go to our
website to see those.
And that's all I have
for you right now.
But I'd be more than
happy to take a couple
of questions if there are any.
>> Detroit Public Library is
celebrating their sesquicentennial,
along with the Detroit
Police Department.
And I wanted to know how would I
with assistance through the Library
of Congress set up a
Sesquicentennial blog
where people tell their
stories and the stories
of their community service
in the city of Detroit.
>> Megan Harris: That's
a great question.
And it gets towards -- the
question was about working
with partner organizations such
as the Detroit Public Library
to donate oral histories
to us and to the library.
And we have organizations that
donate collections ranging
from public libraries to
retirement communities,
to schools from K-12
and universities.
All sorts of organizations.
And so I would definitely encourage
you to go to the public library
and work with the librarians
there to start your own project.
There's not anything
specific that you need to do.
We can get information to you and
I can have some of my colleagues
who work on the programming end
of the project work with you.
But it's really, if you
have the will to start this
up in your community, then
you can go ahead and do that.
Yeah, yeah.
Hi.
>> So I remember a couple of years
ago a student tried to do a project
with the regiments where they
wrote their stories down.
And I know a lot of library
systems are trying to do that now
and get the veterans to come in.
Do you do a partnership
or do you have a program
where they can come together in
a group and record their stories
or write their stories so they
can submit it to the archives?
I'm a veteran myself and I'm
one of the last of the wax.
So mine was from a
reserve point of view
but I think it would
be really important
that all those stories get put in.
So if there's a way that we
as a group can organize
to get the stories in.
>> Megan Harris: Yeah, wonderful.
And yes, definitely.
Even as a reservist, your
story is very important
and we definitely want
it in our archive.
And in terms of working
with community organizations
and with students, we have, like I
said, a lot of different programs
at schools, whether
it's younger students
or older students and universities.
Generally we need stories to be
kind of one-on-one interviews.
But that doesn't preclude
having larger programs.
And I can speak with
you after the program
about your specific community
where you are and see
if there are organizations that
are already set up doing this.
That would be wonderful.
Yeah. Any other questions?
Okay.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: Okay, Let's
thank Megan for her presentation.
[ Applause ]
And we have one more staff member,
Guha Shankar is going to come up
and talk about the Civil
Rights Oral History Project
and a couple of others.
But we have a few late arrivals.
So if you have an empty seat next
to you, could you raise your hand?
So we have a seat up here.
We have a couple right in here.
There's one here.
There's one in the front row here.
And there's a seat over
here in the front row.
Has everybody got a seat yet?
No? Is that a little tight?
Actually there are two seats here.
Okay, so Guha.
Actually, ace you comfortable?
Are you? All right.
Okay, so Guha Shankar.
[ Applause ]
>> Guha Shankar: Hi,
good morning again.
Thank you all for being here.
It's a privilege to be
here in front of you today.
I want to thank my colleagues Todd
Harvey and Megan Harris for doing
such a nice job of
setting up my presentation.
I have very little to say, so
I'm just going to play some clips
for you from two of our
most substantial collections
that document the African American
experience here at the Library
of the American Folk Life Center.
If you look in your packets,
you will see the URLs
for the Civil Rights History Project
and the National Visionary
Leadership Project.
And those are the ones
that I'm going to talk
about mostly in the
time I have here.
And I look around and I think
I see some familiar faces.
So I guess maybe we should
start by acknowledging that many
of you have actually done
research here before.
Is that correct?
Those of you how have
visited our reading room,
raise your hands please.
Excellent.
Thank you.
Well, we welcome all of you, though
not at the same time, to come
and visit our reading rooms.
[ Laughter ]
So make an appointment.
Your best friend is the librarian.
That's us.
I also noticed that with respect
to what Megan has just said
about the experiences of the
service folks here in the library,
and some of you have
identified yourself,
those of you who are veterans
of the armed services,
please raise your hand.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And then the other category
of folks I wanted to call out,
give a shout out to, were
those of you who are involved
in the freedom struggle
from the 1950's
and '60's and on through today.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
All right, so with regard to
that, in your packets you will see
as I said, the URL's for the
Civil Rights History project
from the National Visionary
Leadership Project.
These resources are available to
you online, in your own browser
in the comfort of your own home.
The Civil Rights History Project,
the distinction I will make is
that the Civil Rights
History Project is available
through the website of
the Library of Congress,
as you can see down
here in the corner.
And the National Visionary
Leadership Project,
although the archival materials, the
recordings, are here at the library,
in point of fact the National
Visionary Leadership Project
maintains its own website.
And you can access stories
through their website.
Have you folks visited the
National Visionary Leadership
Project website?
Do you know where that is?
Well, you'll find out.
Okay, all right.
So let me begin first with the
Civil Rights History Project.
I'm the project director here at the
library side for this initiative.
It's a joint effort
between the Library
and the Smithsonian's
National Museum
for African American
History and Culture.
We operate under the
mandate of a public law
that was passed in
2009 by US Congress.
Under the terms of the mandate, the
library and the NMAAHC were directed
to first conduct a survey of
existing oral history collections
with the relevance of the Civil
Rights Movement to obtain justice,
freedom and equality
for African Americans.
And then to record new interviews
with people who have participated
in the struggle, beginning
about 2010.
The initiative ended about 2014.
To that end, we have as you will see
here, over 100 distinct interviews
with members of the struggle.
Ranging from people who
were well-known and famous,
like the Reverend Joseph Lowery,
to others who were frontline
activists whose work is perhaps not
as well known, but whose stories
are compelling nonetheless.
And we have over 100 interviews, and
some of them, just to reference back
to an earlier point,
some of them are done
with multiple people in one setting.
It's a difficult situation
to do something like that.
I can talk about that a
little later when we talk
about the technical aspects of
conducting your own documentation.
So all these materials
are available.
One of the nice things about the
Civil Rights History Project is
that every one of these interviews,
unlike others that you might find,
not just in the library site,
but also across the spectrum
of oral history collections,
they're all fully transcribed.
So you can actually come through
here and search for them according
to locations of where
the interviews were done.
Or where they're referencing events
that were important in the struggle,
like say Birmingham or
Selma and those other places
like St. Augustine Florida,
which was a little less known.
And we have these materials, as
I said, are available on-site.
And if you look for instance at the
subject listing, it will tell you
that these are all the ways
in which you can search
across the collections
and aggregate.
Several interviews will
come up in one place.
So you can search for those
individual interviews.
And you can also do what is the
librarian's best friend now.
You can Google it, which
has now become a verb.
And you can find some of
these materials and some
of these themes embedded
within those transcripts.
So I'm going to sort
of stop talking now
because I think the most important
thing I can do is tell you
that the words of the elders,
the words of the individuals
who we interviewed are paramount.
And here I'll make a distinction
between I think what Todd
and Megan were also talking about.
We serve at the library
the stuff that is the raw.
It's up to you to cook it, right?
So what we're presenting, and
the nice examples that Megan
and Todd presented were extracts
from a larger corpus of materials.
There's 15 hours of material
in the Vera Hall interviews.
Todd pulled together something
that crystalizes what
we think is important
about that particular
collection that speaks
to a certain aspect
of the experience.
We cannot do the research
for you, as you well know.
And find out what those
nuggets of information are.
That's what archival
research is in a lot of cases:
digging down, digging deep.
Gold doesn't just wash up
on the shore in your pan.
You've got to go looking for it.
And that means doing all of this
work like reading through or looking
through over 200 hours of materials
from the Civil Rights
History Project alone.
There are over 300 interviews
in the National Visionary
Leadership Project.
And don't even get us started
about the Alan Lomax collection.
So it's a lifetime worth of work.
I certainly made it my lifetime,
because I've been here a long time.
So I'm happy here.
But you're all welcome to come
and participate with that as well.
So without further ado I'm going
to start with the first interview.
And this is with Sam
Mahone who was interviewed
in Albany, Georgia in 2013.
Sam Mahone was a Civil
Rights Activist
with a student nonviolent
coordinating community
in America's Georgia College
of Art Institute of Atlanta,
working several art
museums and galleries.
In this interview he discusses his
experience of racial segregation,
discrimination in America's Georgia.
And the experiences which were
on the heels of the passage
of the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
How many of you have been
to the Civil Rights
exhibit here in the library?
Well, you all must
be from out of town.
So if you haven't done it, go.
Not now, but go after
this presentation.
Go to that exhibition.
It's replete with a lot of just
fascinating material, artifacts,
objects, transcripts and several
oral histories, interviews,
not just from our collections
but from collections
across the breadth of the library.
You'd find yourself really
well-suited for that.
So I want to play this first
clip, which is from Sam Mahone.
>> I finished high school and
then I joined State and began
to continue working throughout
our reference, but I also worked
in other counties,
surrounding counties as well.
Continued doing voter registration
and continued doing a lot
of public accommodation
and what have you.
I remember the night the Civil
Rights Bill was passed we decided we
were going to test it
at a local restaurant.
>> This is July '64?
>> Exactly.
Myself and John Padoe
who I believe is here,
who was one of the
America's state workers.
Bob Mince, Adam Wolhouse
who recently passed away.
And four of the students.
We went down to a place called
The Hasty House restaurant.
And we sat there and
we tried to order food,
but the waitress never came.
One of the guys who was with us said
he needed to go to the restroom.
And the restroom was outside.
You had to go outside and go
around the side of the building.
Well while we were waiting, the
woman came to take our order,
but about 10 minutes
passed and we realized
that he hadn't come
back from the restroom.
So we finally decided
to get up to leave.
And as we get up to leave to go out
to the car, we were met by a group
of whites who had come across
the street from a service station
with tire irons and baseball bats.
And so they waited until
we got into the car,
which was a convertible car.
And then they just rained down
on the car with baseball bats
and tire irons, beating
us on top of our heads.
And we finally get the car started
and we just get out of there
without the guy who had
gone to the restroom.
Well he shows up about two days
later and he says what happened is
that when he went to the restroom
he was attacked and beaten
and he just ran off
and never came back.
And so that was the first evening
we decided to test the laws
that Congress had passed.
>> Guha Shankar: So that's that
moment of deep personal experience.
And this is a person
operating from 50 year memory.
And I think many of you might have
similar memories of experiences
that just burned so deeply
into you that you recount it
as though it were yesterday.
I'd be interested in finding out how
and in what way storytellers craft
these kinds of personal experiences
into stories for your own use
and for sharing more widely
with the world outside.
The second clip is
from Bill Saunders,
who was born in New York, New York.
Married Henrietta Jenkins
and had 10 children.
Mr. Saunders attended
Southern Business College,
Southern Illinois University,
vocational education,
and the University of Nevada.
He worked as a politician and
was also the CEO of the committee
on Better Racial Assurance
Human Services Agency.
He was interviewed for this
project down in South Carolina.
And in this interview he recalls
serving the Army during the
Korean War.
And speaks of his experiences
with racism
in the national army at that time.
And I think those of you who have
relatives who you have spoken to,
members of our service people,
and particularly of that era,
will know how deeply those
experiences influence their
subsequent activism in
the freedom struggle.
So I want to play this
particular clip from Mr. Saunders.
>> You confronted more racism in
Hawaii than you had encountered
on Johns Island or
in Charleston even?
>> Hawaii and the military
even in Korea.
The racisms was real,
real bad in Korea.
And then Hawaii.
And I just realized later
on, it was right after 1851.
They had just really
integrated the army.
There were four blacks in our
company, one Hispanic, one Indian.
And I didn't realize until
many years later that all
of these people, poor white men,
who also had a lot of problems.
And the only place
they could vet any
of those problems was
on people like me.
So they had their own problem
reasons and we had a lot of fights.
>> Do you remember
particular instances?
>> Physical fights.
A guy will beat me,
but my grandmother gave
me such a bad temper.
I get real mad, I don't give up.
So I don't stop when
people say to stop.
So I end up being the
one getting in trouble.
But they did so many
things to the blacks.
We had one guy, one of my best
friends who died recently,
they made him dig a 6x6x6 hole and
they decided to drop a dime in it
and then make him close it up.
Those were the kinds of
things we went through.
And a lot of it coming back
to me more and more now.
I'm having a lot of
flashbacks with that.
Even in Korea, the war, I mean
the guy who was my first sergeant
who I didn't know, on the front
lines we just fought for two days.
And I was going up the hill on top
and he said, "Blacks are difficult.
I'll blow your brains out."
And he had a .45 on me.
And I decided at that point -- my
rifle was in the hole I was going
to roll and get my gun
like you saw from a movie.
Man, that .45 will blow a
hole straight through you.
Because I've seen a
.45 shoot people.
I went back to my hole
and stayed there.
When it was time for us to
leave, he sent for me and said
that he had made me lead the whole
company out there because being
in front you get killed first.
So he wanted me killed
out in front going out.
That was the kind of stuff.
So there was a lot of stuff
that we can laugh about,
because if you don't
you cry about it.
So but the racism was
just really heavy.
Coming back, even in California
when we got back as heroes,
because I got wounded, there in
California they started calling
out the white soldiers' names
and then the called blacks.
I never understood
that until we got on.
But black and white
soldiers couldn't ride
in the same train coach
across America.
So we had to ride in
separate coaches.
>> Guha Shankar: Okay, I'm going
to wrap this up because I want
to make sure we have
some time for questions.
The other collections that I
might sort of point you to,
and my colleague Catherine
Kerst will talk
about some of these a little later.
But again in your packet you will
notice a URL for Born in Slavery:
Slave Narratives from the
Federal Writers Project.
And this is more than 2,300
first-person accounts of slavery
and also photographs
of former slaves.
And these narratives were
collected in the 1930's as part
of the Federal Writers Project of
the Works Progress Administration,
a federal project, by the way.
And assembled and microfilmed
in 1941 as the Slave Narratives,
which is this mammoth 17-volume set.
Published and available to you.
And the online collect I think
might be interesting for you all
because it actually has facsimiles
of all of the various narratives
that have been digitized and put
up online so you can scan those.
They have some subject
terms and so on,
but they're not fully transcribed
as are the Civil Rights
History project.
So with that I'm going
to bring this to a close
and thank you for your patience.
I know it's already
been a little long.
But we'll move on.
And if there are any
questions I'd be happy
to entertain them either
here or afterwards.
>> In which way are you
connected with Story Corps?
Because they have been going
around, you know collecting stories
and I've even joined in
telling people about it.
>> Guha Shankar: Story
Corps is archived here.
The materials, the recordings
are archived here at the Library
of the American Folk Life Center.
Again, you can get access to those.
It's an enormous volume of stories,
so we can't provide online
access to all of them.
But if you make an appointment
with our library staff,
with our American Folk Life Center
reference staff, you all can come in
and listen to those stories.
And some of them, as you
know, are available in bits
and pieces here and there.
That's the nuggets that
get extracted by NPR
for their programs as well.
So that's one way to do it.
And participation is
an interesting one.
We can direct you to the
Story Corps site and tell you
when the mobile trucks and
buses show up in your area.
And you might want to think about
working on a way to get your stories
or the individuals whose
stories you think are important
into that archive.
Yes ma'am?
>> I wanted to share with
NABS that Mary Carter Smith
and Victoria Smith were
recorded by Story Corps,
so they are here with you.
>> Guha Shankar: Yes.
Thank you very much
for your contributions.
I appreciate it.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: All right.
Oh, one more question and
then we'll take a break.
>> Next year in 2017 will
be the 50th anniversary
of the Detroit Riot, and I wanted
to know would it be possible to set
up a Story Corps bus or
whatever at that time?
>> Guha Shankar: That would
be a very good question
and we can refer you to
the Story Corps folks.
They might actually
be in partnership
with the local organizations
in Detroit
to do something like that already.
I guess that's one of the things
I want to mention to you is
that we're the national library, but
we're not quite the national mafia
and we really believe that our local
partners are every bit as important
with the collecting
efforts that you all do.
So we would encourage you strongly
to contact your local libraries.
They are the community centers at
their very best and they are places
that your stories can be collected.
They can help you with
documentation efforts.
And they can help you find stories
and that's really what we say,
is that the library is in
your backyard and it's one
of the greatest resources
that we have.
And we are always proud to
partner with those folks
to do precisely the kind of
efforts you were talking about.
Okay.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: Okay,
so let's come back at 10:40
and you'll hear more
about the collections
at the Library of Congress.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Singing ]
>> VM: So I'm guessing
by the amount of cheers
that this person is no
stranger to y'all's association.
So this was a recording of Linda
at the National Storytelling
Festival, somewhere in the 1970's.
And I'm glad that you enjoy that.
Good morning.
I am Valda Morris and I'm
a processing archivist here
at the American Folk Life Center.
And I want to piggyback
off of something
that my colleague Guha
said about we are archives
and we give the raw materials.
And it's up to you
all to find that gold.
And Linda, Ms. Goss was
actually here a couple years ago.
She had won one of our grants.
And she actually was able
to research and she was able
to enrich our collections even more
because she was able to fill in some
of the gaps and the
questions that I had
about the National
Storytelling Festival.
So that's just you know, another
plug for you all to come in
and do some research here at
our American Folk Life Center.
Okay, so I would like to
personally welcome all of y'all
and every single member of
NABS to the Library of Congress
to the American Folk
Life Center and to DC.
I'm really excited here this
morning to be able to share some
of the wonderful storyteller
resources that you have just seen --
that you're about to
see from my colleagues
and that you're about
to see from me.
That are actually housed here at
the American Folk Life Center.
Some of these resources
are not just on paper
or what we call manuscript
materials.
But they are sound recordings,
they're graphic images, you know,
photos and prints and stuff.
And moving images.
We have also digitized a large
amount of these materials
and we're working on
digitizing another set.
And some of these that are not
digitized, you can also request
and we could do it
for you on-demand.
Today I will share some of the
recordings that are both sound
and moving images that are
part of story collections here
at the American Folk Life Center.
The first one is a James
Carpenter collection
and then the other would
be the International
Storytelling Collection.
The earliest recordings of
American Folk Tales that we have
in our archives that are actually
done on wax cylinder recordings.
So just imagine like a
candle with a hole in it
and they have grooves in there.
That's one of the earliest
recordings
that we have of sound recordings.
And these were made in the
1930's by Harvard-trained scholar
from Mississippi, a person by the
name of James Madison Carpenter.
Carpenter was best known
for his ballads and songs
and he collected a lot of stories
in England, Scotland and Wales.
However, he was also a
teacher at Duke University.
And that's where he identified a
janitor there by the name of John.
And these became important
because they were the
earliest known field recordings
of African American folktales
within the United States.
I'm going to play you a brief sample
of James' wax cylinder recording
of John telling the story
of Jack and the Devil.
So you image that these
are some old recordings,
so the quality is not
going to be that great.
But if you listen clearly
you will hear when he begins.
"Once upon a time there
was a boy named Jack."
>> Once upon a time there was
a boy by the name of Jack.
[ Inaudible ]
>> VM: All right, I know that
wasn't the best, but we have a lot
of these recordings in our
James Carpenter Collection,
just waiting to be
discovered by you.
Carpenter completed his field
recordings and manuscripts.
His complete field recordings and
manuscripts will be online in 2016
as part of the digital archives.
The Full English, hosted
by the English Folk
and Song Society in London.
Okay. The International
Story Collection is one
of our largest collections
that we received here in 2001.
It was actually 500,000 items came.
And it documents the beginning
of the International
Storytelling Center
and all the different
variations that it had.
And of course you know it hosts the
International Storytelling Festival.
And have featured many black
storytellers over the ages.
Mary Catherine Smith, Linda
Goss, Jackie Torrence,
Charlotte Bri Alsom, which I
think I see her down there.
Donna Washington, Bro.
Blue, Lyn Cabral, Paul Keems Douglas
and that's just to name a few.
We have many, many
others in the collection.
In 2001 we actually digitized the
real-to-real sound recordings,
which documents the beginnings
of the festival, right
up to the 1990's.
And then we continue to
digitize the docs which came,
which kind of like took up from
that era right up to the 2000's.
We know we receive a lot of the
storytelling stories on hard drives,
so we just upload them
directly to our servers.
The collection is an
open collection.
We have a corporate
agreement with them,
which means we receive their
materials every three years
for the life of the
Center and of the festival.
In 2012, in an effort to
celebrate the 40th anniversary
with the International
Storytelling Center,
we at the American Folk Life
digitized a set of tapes
and we put it all together and we
produced a piece entitled Echoes
from the National Storytelling
Festival.
So I opened with Linda
Goss as you saw,
and that was part of this piece.
And now I'm going to
close with another icon
to the storytelling festival.
Her name is Jackie Torrence.
And I would like to thank
you for your patience.
And enjoy DC and enjoy
the Library of Congress
and we're looking forward
to serving you more.
[ Applause ]
>> Now Brer Rabbit
was a fine fisherman.
All he had to do was go down
to the river, drop his pole in
and with inside of 10 minutes
he'd have 20 fish right
up there on the bank.
He was a good fisherman.
Brer Rabbit had a good friend,
his best friend in fact,
whose name was Brer Raccoon.
But Brer Rabbit called
him Brer Coon for short.
Brer Coon couldn't fish a toad.
He didn't even like fish.
What he liked was frogs.
Brer Coon would go down to the river
with a big tow sack and he'd fill
that sack full of frogs and
he'd take them home to his wife
and his wife would say, "Woohoo!
Frogs!"
[ Laughter ]
Now Brer Coon loved frogs.
But the frogs was getting tired
of Brer Coon catching them.
So they had a big frog meeting.
And they said, "We's got to
do something about Brer Coon.
He's coming down here
and catching us.
We got to find out where he
is and when he's coming."
So they decided to put a
lookout frog on the bank.
They needed a frog with big eyes.
A frog that could hear
good from a long way.
A frog that could see
real good, see him coming.
They only frog they could see
with them qualifications
was the bullfrog.
So they put him down on the
riverbank to watch for Brer Coon.
Brer Coon would get a half
a mile down to the river
and the bullfrog would see him.
And the bullfrog would warn
all the rest of the frogs.
And you could hear him
say, "Here he comes."
[ Laughter ]
"Here he comes."
And the little frogs would echo
what the bullfrog had said.
"Here he comes."
[ Laughter ]
"Here he comes.
Here he comes."
Well by the time Brer
Coon got to the river,
all the frogs had leaped
into the water.
And there wasn't a frog in sight.
And ole Brer Coon couldn't go in
the water because he couldn't swim.
He'd go home with that empty
tow sack and his wife would say,
"Is you coming in here
without a frog?"
[ Laughter ]
And Brer Coon would
say, "Now wait a minute.
I can't catch them frogs.
They done got to wild.
I've been down there
and every time I go
down there they say, "Here he comes.
Here he comes.
Here he comes."
[ Laughter ]
>> Catherine Kerst:
High, I'm Cathy Kerst.
I'm a folklorist and archivist
in the American Folk Life center.
And I'll be talking
to you about some
of the Zora Neale Hurston materials
that we have in our archive
and also elsewhere in
the Library of Congress.
We are thrilled to have
you here, really pleased.
In 1938, Zora Neale Hurston wrote
an essay called Folklore in Music,
intended to be published in a
work called The Florida Negro.
In it she wrote, as
Betsy has already said,
"Folklore is the boiled
down juice of human living.
It does not belong to any
special time, place nor people.
In folklore, as in everything
else that people create,
the world is a great
big old serving platter.
And all the places are
like eating plates.
Whatever is on the plates
must come out of the platter,
but each plate has
a flavor of its own.
Because the people take
the universal stuff
and season it to suit themselves.
And this local flavor is what
is known as originality."
She wrote so beautifully.
Known by many as a literary
figure, a gifted author,
Hurston was also an astute
and perceptive ethnographer
and interviewer.
She studied anthropology at
Columbia University in the mid-20's
where she was encouraged to
travel to her native Florida
to gather African American folklore.
Which she did.
The American Folk Life
Center holds a variety
of fascinating Hurston materials
relating to this research.
Our Hurston collections include
for the most part audio recordings
that she collected from
individuals or groups,
or were made of her own
speaking and singing
in Florida and Georgia in 1935.
In Haiti in 1936.
In Washington, D. C. at the
National Folk Festival in 1938.
And during her work for
the Federal Writers Project
in Florida in 1938 and -39.
We also have a few
letters in our collection.
Here is a photo of Hurston
which we believe was taken
at a recording site in 1935.
The photo resides in the prints
and photographs division
here at the library.
It was really hard to decide what
audio recordings to play for you
since so much of it
is so compelling.
I've chosen three selections
from the late 1930's
that feature Hurston
speaking and singing
and demonstrate her ethnographic
eye and documentary style.
In April of 1938 Hurston
joined the staff
of the Florida Federal
Writers Project
to collect African American
folklore in Florida.
The Federal Writers Project was part
of the Works Progress Administration
where authors, historians,
artists and folklorists
like Hurston were hired to collect
folklore, history, oral narratives,
songs and more to document the lives
of ordinary Americans
from many backgrounds.
As part of her work, Hurston
collected folk speech, work songs,
tall tales and lies,
narratives about preachers,
children's games and much more.
I'm focusing today on the
recordings where you get a chance
to hear Hurston's voice
and experience her method
of documenting folk culture.
These recordings are all on the
Library of Congress's website.
This is a description
of track lining.
>> Now when the men are lining,
they put the rail down and then
of course the captain, he squats
straddle of it and looks down it
so he can tell when it's lined
up in exact line with the others.
And he'll say, "Shove it over."
And the captain, he'll
say, "Send it back."
And when they get it
exactly in line,
he'll tell them, "Join it ahead."
But they corrupted
that to "Joiner ahead."
And all of them said, "Joiner
head," for "Join it ahead."
And so this song is about lining
and the rhythm goes with this.
They put this lining bar,
this long steel bar, crow bar,
between their legs so they have
greater push and pull back on it.
[ Inaudible ]
Their back is to the rail.
They're pulling up on the bar.
They don't have to look at the rail,
because that's the captain's
job to see when it's right.
>> How do they get
it under the rail?
>> They just push the flange of
this lining bar onto the rail
and then pull back on it.
>> Do they have to look back at it?
>> Catherine Kerst: You
can hear Herbert Kelford,
one of the other Federal Writers
Project workers asking all sorts
of questions.
So Zora was interested
in documenting how things were done
sometimes in traditional culture.
And the next recording
is Shove It Over,
which is actually the work song that
goes along with the track lining.
Sort of like a call and response
chant used on the railroad.
>> This song is called Shove It Over
and it's the lining rhythm
pretty generally distributed all
over Florida.
It was sung to me by Charlie Jones
on the railroad construction
camp near Lakeland, Florida.
>> How long ago?
>> I gathered that in '33, 1933.
[ Singing ]
>> Catherine Kerst: And here is
Uncle Bud, which is a social song,
a body juke song sung by Hurston.
It was collected by Stetson
Kennedy who was recording her
and whose voice you also
hear on this recording.
1939 in Jacksonville.
>> Uncle Bud is not a works song.
It's a sort of social
song for amusement
and it's so widely distributed.
It's growing all the time
by incremental repetition.
And it is known all over the south.
No matter where you go, you
can find versions of Uncle Bud.
And it's a favorite song and the men
get to working in every kind of way.
And they just yell
down to Uncle Bud.
And nobody in particular leads it.
Everybody puts in his
verse when he gets ready.
And Uncle Bud goes
and goes and goes.
>> Wow. Was it sung before
the respectable ladies?
>> Never. It's one
of those juke songs.
Any woman that they sing Uncle
Bud in front of is a juke woman.
>> I thought you heard it from them.
>> Yes, I heard it from them.
[Singing] Uncle Bud's
a man, a man like this.
He can't get a woman,
got to use his fists.
Uncle Bud, Uncle Bud, Uncle
Bud, Uncle Bud, Uncle Bud.
Oh go to town, got to hurry back,
Uncle Bud's got something
I sure do like.
Uncle Bud, Uncle Bud, Uncle
Bud, Uncle Bud, Uncle Bud.
Oh, little cat, big cat, little
bitty kitten, gonna work that tale,
but they don't stop shitting.
Uncle Bud, Uncle Bud, Uncle
Bud, Uncle Bud, Uncle Bud.
Uncle Bud got caught knee jerking,
Uncle Bud's got gout
that sure needs working.
Uncle Bud, Uncle Bud, Uncle
Bud, Uncle Bud, Uncle Bud.
>> Catherine Kerst: You can
hear the rest of it online.
[ Laughter ]
So I have a few photographs from
the prints and photographs division.
These are from Hurston's
1935 research with Edenville,
Florida children documenting
their games and songs.
With the field research done
by Hurston and the researchers
in the 1930's during the New Deal
Era, the lives, music, speech,
memories and artistic efforts of
ordinary Americans were documented.
The Library of Congress holds a
huge amount of New Deal materials.
And in the American Folk
Life Center we were honored
to also house a wealth of
this material including these
and other stunning examples
of Hurston's voice, vitality,
with and deep cultural
understanding.
The Hurston recordings I
played for you, plus many more,
are accessible online at
the library's website.
And on the handout in your packet
you will find a finding aid
to Zora Neale Hurston materials
throughout the library.
Manuscript division, prints
and photographs and so on.
I recommend that you explore them.
And now I want to talk very
briefly about Voices from the Days
of Slavery: Former
Slaves Tell their Stories.
So if you go to the American Folk
Life Center homepage and look at all
of the online collections,
there are quite a few.
There is Voices from
the Days of Slavery.
And I just urge you to
take a look at this site.
The site includes seven hours of
recorded interviews that took place
between 1932 and 1975
in nine southern states.
On these recordings, 23
persons were interviewed born
between 1823 and the early 1860's.
In the interviews they discuss
how they felt about slavery,
about slaveholders,
the coercion of slaves,
their families and about freedom.
The variety of topics, personal
experiences and feelings
that are conveyed are incredibly
moving and quite remarkable.
Being able to actually able
to hear their voices and all.
Included in the collection is an
interview that Hurston took part
in with Wallace Porterman
in 1935 in Georgia.
This whole collection of audio
recordings is available here
on this site.
And it includes transcriptions
of the narratives to help
in understanding dialect
and understanding some
of the older recordings
that are a little scratchy.
Anyway, thank you.
Thank you so much for coming.
It's a pleasure having you here.
And we urge you to
come and visit us.
There's a lot to explore.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Guha Shankar: Hello again.
Right, this is going to be
the high-speed version of how
to conduct audio documentation,
or cultural documentation.
Before we do that, I wanted to
make a couple of announcements.
First of all I want to
thank a couple of people
who have not been acknowledged
so far.
Frist and foremost or events
production coordinator,
Thea Austin who has put this
program together for you.
There she is right there.
[ Applause ]
And Dana Bell who is in the back,
who put together the wonderful
list of resources for you.
[ Applause ]
And many others too numerous to
name at this particular point.
By rights, this next session,
which I'm going to do at top speed
in about 15 minutes, leaving
some time for questions,
is generally the focus on various
training programs that we conduct
at the library through
various institutional partners
across the country to orient
people like yourselves who wish
to do cultural documentation in your
communities for various purposes.
Whether it's for podcasts,
whether it's for collecting stories
of elders and community members,
class projects and so on.
And the things that we often
get asked go along the lines of,
"How do I do it?
What equipment do I use?
And how do I do interviews?"
I'm going to concentrate on those
three things because it's a topic
which as I said, covers
about three weeks in duration
when we teach our annual
field schools.
This is not for the faint-hearted.
How many of you have done collecting
oral history interviews yourselves?
Well, you know, I should get you
all to come up here and do this.
[ Laughter ]
But I think they will tell you
that be prepared, be careful
and be cautious about
what you are embarking on.
It's not a project for
the faint of heart.
Our colleague Todd Harvey,
very generously said
that he would take the documentation
that you're going to collect.
I will caution you that while
we are welcoming of collections,
we also are acutely aware, given
where we stand in terms of trying
to archive and sustain
these materials,
and sustainability
is a keyword for us.
When we say sustain we mean not just
to have these stories accessible the
day after you record them and so on,
but generations down the line.
The recordings that you
have here from the Lomax's,
from the Civil Rights
History Project,
from the Federal Writers Project and
so on, have stood the test of time.
Because there is a body of people
and there's an entire
institution devoted to making sure
that these materials are
available and accessible to you.
I do not believe, unless you are
really well-funded trust fund
hippies, that you've got
that kind of manpower
and resources at your disposal.
That's where the library
and other institutions
in your community come into play.
But even then, even with all
of our interests in maintaining
and preserving our collections,
there are certain things
that we would ask that you
do in terms of making sure
that your materials are
going to be available
and accessible over
the course of time.
One of the things that we ask
in the first place is
understand what the parameters
of your project are.
To take inventory of the
resources that you have
so that you can then embark upon a
project of cultural documentation
and interviewing very carefully.
One of the things I will show
you here is on our website.
This particular thing is called
the cultural documentation, methods
and techniques, on that site.
And within the site we have
provided some basic guidelines
and best practices documents
that you may wish to consult.
There are many of these
around the country.
Many institutions like Baylor's Oral
History Association have similar
sets of guidelines.
The Smithsonian Institution's
Folk Life programs,
the Center for Folk Life and
Heritage Research have their own set
of rubrics and best practices.
We generally bring these materials
together from our colleagues
across these institutions because
we've been at it for a long time
and our roles as ethnographers, as
folklorists, as anthropologists,
as ethnomusicologists, and we
always lean upon our colleagues
to keep us abreast
of best practices.
So one of the things I would
urge you to do is when you get
to the site and you're
interested in trying to figure
out what the parameters of
such projects are is to go
to this link here you'll see, called
cultural documentation guidelines.
And within that you
have various aspects
of what the broad categories
are that one needs to think
about when engaging in projects
of cultural documentation.
Some of these are more
relevant to you than others.
I'm not planning on going
through all of them.
But one of the very first
things we suggest is
that you actually do a
project plan, all right?
And what we're asking you to
do again is take an inventory
of the resources that you have.
If you don't already have equipment,
if you don't already have a place
to have these materials rest,
then you're going to have to think
about it at the head end.
Many project runs afoul
of one very basic thing.
Nobody thought through what
the end result was going to be
and where it was going to live.
People come to these
projects and they say,
"We're going to document this
particular community member
or these particular community
members because there's an urgency."
You get halfway through
the project and you find
that you don't know
where to store them.
You find that you don't
have an idea of what sorts
of topics you might
want to embark upon.
You have a broad idea,
but the specific historical
facts are not available to you.
You find out that your
technical needs are inadequate
to the subject matter at hand.
So there's a very simple spreadsheet
that our colleagues Paula Johnson
at the Smithsonian
Institution, she's a curator there
and a folklorist, and our own David
Taylor who used to work with us here
at the Library of Congress, have
put together several years ago.
And I've modified this
over the course of time.
But it asks you to take
account of very basic things
like a budget, what are your goals.
What other kind of
research has been done?
Do you have a body of
materials to draw upon?
Would you need to consult
for instance International
Storytelling Collection to figure
out if the people whom you want
to interview have already
been interviewed?
Or if they've been interviewed,
if they've been documented,
is there something else
in the historical record
that needs fleshing out?
So thorough research is one of
the things that we ask you to do.
And then you just precisely ask,
where are you going to do the work?
Is it a national collecting project
like this Civil Rights
History Project?
Probably not.
I mean, you've got to have
money for funding and you have
to have funding for
travel and so on.
So maybe it's in your backyard.
One of the things we ask you
is are you planning on --
what sort of documentation
are you going to do?
Is it audio recording?
In my view that's the best
and the simplest method
of recording stories.
Video recording and videotaping,
it looks great, it looks sexy,
all hi-def and all of that.
If you don't have the expertise
to do that, you're going to have
to bring some people in who can
help you do that documentation.
That adds to the resources
that you're going to need.
That adds to the money, right?
You're going to have
to get equipment.
You're going to have to buy it.
You're going to have to rent it.
You're going to have to
do something with it.
Even if you were to
work in partnership
with a particular institution,
you're going to have
to understand what their technical
limitations are, who they can lend
to the project and so on.
Are you going to do photography?
Those photographs, images, as Cathy
and others have shown you are
really important to give a face
to the voices that you hear
online or anywhere else.
And all of these materials, all of
these kinds of very detailed things
that we're asking you to
consider are important
because they will play
a part in how well
and how well-sustained your
materials are going to be
in an archival situation.
I do not believe -- I heard
a young lady ask a question
over here about recording.
That the stories that she
wants to collect are going
to just live in here and the now.
Again, I go back to
that point earlier:
you're trying to make these
publicly available and acceptable
to generations of people
that come after you.
You do that through
your storytelling.
Consider the fact that the materials
that you collect, the documentation,
the firsthand experiences that
you collect, have to live.
If they don't live, then they
don't enter public memory.
They don't enter American
historical consciousness.
So it's up to you.
Because you guys are
mediating between the voice
of the person whom you're collecting
and everybody else in this room
and people you don't even know.
Right? That's the generational
aspect of all of this.
So think through all of these
questions very carefully.
Now let me see if I can -- so the
project plan is available online
in this particular website.
The second thing we get asked is,
what equipment do we want to use?
The Library of Congress,
being a public institution,
can neither confirm nor deny that
there are better grades of equipment
than others, although I could tell
you that off-camera somewhere.
So we rely again on our colleagues
like Doug Boyd, who is the director
of the Oral History
Association's Oral History
in the Digital Age Project.
And this to me is one
of the great tools.
I keep hoping for the day
and keep toying with the idea
that there might be a
similar set of rubrics
that we could use for
video recording.
Video recording is a
whole other animal.
What we're dealing here with is
almost a transparent interaction
in terms of audio recording
between you as a collector
and the person that
you're recording.
There's not a lot of equipment.
There's not a lot of people
trailing wires behind them
as is the case with video.
You don't have to have
a video operator.
You can with practice get really
good at conducting an interview,
a story collecting project
with just you and the person
that you wish to document.
And to that end, people say, "What
kind of equipment should I get?"
And we say, well, here's
what you do.
You go in here and you go
to this particular website.
This is the Oral History
in the Digital Age site.
And right here is this
thing called go to ask Doug.
And digital expert Doug Boyd, fellow
folklorist, oral historian and all
around good guy has done this
really, really neat thing here.
And what he says is,
it's very simple.
It's radio buttons and checkboxes.
If I can do it, you can do it.
And basically says things like it
goes back to your project planning.
How much money do you
have to get a recorder?
Right? He asks you
question like quality.
What is it you want to do with this?
Is it professional level quality?
Are you the person who's
facile with technical equipment
that you can say, "I want the best
and the brightest, the lates"?
Then you check this box that
says professional quality.
But you still want to keep it
somewhere in the $500 range.
And then Doug very
helpfully has told you
that he considers this
the best in class.
This is something that
people like Doug can do.
That is to say they can actually put
their hands on pieces of equipment.
And I can guarantee you
that you have some assurance
that it is what he says it is.
What he says it is in the box will
actually be what's delivered to you.
One of the things that we
often say is that you know
that people are lying
when they tell you
to have archival quality
CD's and DVD's.
There's no such thing.
Right? But with this particular
project you can understand
as Doug says that there are these
classes of recorders and every one
of them comes with an explanation of
what the equipment is, what it does,
tells you where to go buy them.
All right?
Making sense?
All right.
So that's one of the
recommendations that we would have.
So mark this down if it's
not already in your package,
prepared very nicely by Dana.
Right? We can come back to this
in just a second, all right?
Whoops, what happened here?
Hang on. Yes, thank you.
All right, and let me go back
to one more particular
aspect of this website.
So far we talked about
project planning,
understanding what you want to do
and who you want to
do it with and so on.
We talk about very basic equipment
and now comes what happens
when you go to the actual
interview situation?
And this should be no
surprise to those of you
who have done cultural
documentation,
who have done interviews.
But one of the things we do is
we say these are best practices
and guidelines for
conducting recorded interviews.
And not all of these
are going to come
up in your particular
situation, but check these out.
Sort of take them to heart and
understand what they are in terms
of your own particular
documentary situation.
We just go through a list of stuff.
It's not a template.
It's not the Bible.
We're not saying you
have to follow it
from point one to point
20 or whatever.
But this enables you to get the
story and the voices of people
that you're wanting to document
in as clear and as concise
and as precise a fashion
as possible.
And above all, one of the things
that we say is right here.
That I think is probably as
germain to you all as anything else.
And all it says is you're
not just after the facts.
You want stories, narratives
and explanations, right?
You're storytellers yourselves,
so you just have to figure out how
to mesh the things that you do with
the people whom you're talking to.
And elicit those stories so that
it makes sense for you and for all
of us who will hear it later on.
Okay. So my 10 minutes are up and I
think the buses are about to come.
But I will be happy to
take some -- yes ma'am.
[ Inaudible ]
It just says avoid questions
-- it's just a guideline.
It says avoid questions that can
be answered with a yes or a no.
You're not just after the fact.
You want stories, narratives
and explanations.
That and many more helpful tips
are available on this guide.
Thank you very much.
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible ]
Guha Shankar.
You can get ahold of me
here at GShankar@LOC.gov.
Do you have other questions?
>> Do you have business cards?
>> I don't have 125 of them, sorry.
Yes ma'am?
[ Inaudible ]
Some of the pictures we have online.
Some of them are in the
public domain and can be used,
but some of them we ask that
you figure out the provenance
of each collection because they
are copyrighted by the donors.
And there's also user and performer
rights that you want to be aware of.
In a lot of cases we ask even if
they've been donated to the library
that as a courtesy you
contact the performer,
the person whose image comes
up in those photographs
and/or their estates.
Just as a courtesy.
Say, "Can we use this
in our own work?"
Okay? Anything else?
GShankar. First name
is Guha, G-u-h-a.
@LOC.gov. Or you can just get
me through FolkLife@LOC.gov.
And all that information
is available
at our website right at
the LOC.gov/folklife.
And all of that information is
in your packets, by the way.
A lot of this information
is in your packets,
so you're quite welcome
to contact us.
Thea has final announcements.
>> Thea Austin: Yes, so there are --
as your glorious leader here has
told you, there are three buses.
One group of people is going to
be staying behind a little bit,
waiting for the last bus.
And I urge you to take a look at
the Civil Rights History exhibit.
That's one floor up,
on the second floor.
If you're going to be staying
here for a little while longer,
hang back a little bit and
let the people who are going
to be exiting the building
first go through the door.
We have a couple of staff people
to help you either take the
elevator or take the stairs.
There's one exit.
And we'll help you
get back to the foyer
where you got off the
bus originally.
So thank you again.
Let's thank Guha for
his presentation.
[ Applause ]
Valda, Cathy Kerst.
All of the staff.
Thank you so much for coming.
We really enjoyed presenting
our collections to you today.
And we hope that you'll
come back and do research
with the American Folk
Life center at the library.
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.